I mean just it doesn't match up the
evidence is pointing against what she's
saying I've gotten requests from my
friends family members patients and
everyone in between
to discuss this plan Demick I usually
try make my videos on the shorter side
but I want to take this one point by
point to give you the clearest picture
of what my thoughts are on this as a
doctor dr. Judy Mike Ovitz has been
called one of the most accomplished
scientist of her generation so you made
a discovery that conflicted with the
agreed upon narrative correct quick note
before we start the focus of my review
here will be based on science and facts
for the sake of Education there's very
little value in speculating on stories
and claims that cannot be verified I am
a doctor and not a detective and I don't
want to turn this into a character
assassination if we don't stop this now
we can not only forget our republic in
our freedom but we can forget humanity
because we'll be killed by this agenda
the man who is heading the pandemic task
force was involved in a cover-up he
directed the cover-up and in fact
everybody else was paid off I just want
to look at the facts and so far very few
facts have been presented when to repeat
this phrase I feel like a lot
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence
what he's saying is absolute propaganda
and and the same kind of propaganda that
he's perpetrated to kill millions since
1984 that virus was spread through
because of the arrogance of a group of
people and it includes Robert Redfield
who's now the head of the CDC they were
working together to take credit and make
money and they had the patents on it and
tailored them to il-2 therapy which was
absolutely the wrong therapy and had
that not happened millions wouldn't have
died from HIV when I first saw that I
was moved I was like wait can it be
possible that these doctors these
researchers for major government
organizations are making millions of
dollars at the expense of millions of
people dying so I looked into it and I
stumbled upon an article in the British
Medical Journal which is a highly highly
respected medical journal
agency reported that two leading
researchers anthony fauci head of the ni
a d and his deputy Clifford Lane
received payments relating to their
development of il-2 as a treatment for
HIV / aids dr. Lane told the BMJ
that the payment was part of his federal
compensation he explained that the
government patented the development and
shared the payments it received with the
inventors since 1997 he has received
about $45,000 she's saying that Clifford
Lane the deputy of the niaD
and doctor foul Chi did this for forty
five thousand dollars to forego your
Creed to protect people and instead to
watch millions died dr. Anthony foul she
told the BMJ that as a government
employee he was required by law to put
his name on the patent for the
development of aisle two and was also
required by law to receive a part of the
payment the government received for use
of the patent he said that he felt it
was inappropriate to receive payment and
donated the entire amount to charity if
she wants me to believe the claims she's
making here she needs to disprove this
this is one of the things that I've been
saying and would like to say to
president Trump repeal the bayh-dole act
that Act gave government workers the
right to patent their discoveries so to
to claim intellectual property for
discoveries that the taxpayer paid for
ever since that happened
in the early eighties it destroyed
science the by Doyle Act was an act that
was passed with bipartisan support both
Democrats and Republicans supported
because they saw the value in it
initially the way scientific research
was funded by the federal government
would be they would give money to a
research institution and whatever that
research institution found the
government would own the patent to it
now in theory this is great because the
government would own that patent and
then if they wanted to use it or sell it
all the money would come back to the
taxpayers but in practice it's not what
happened what actually happened was the
government collected all these patents
and then 95% of them sat collecting dust
making no money for the taxpayer
and no scientific revolution was
happening so now after by Doyle what's
happening is Harford gets a small grant
for the government less than three
million dollars usually they find some
kind of interesting piece of preliminary
research they patent it and then they
license it out to private companies who
invest heavily in the promise of getting
one of these drugs and making money in
the future and from that scientific
innovation flourishes and as a side
benefit the taxpayers make more money
because of this bile Doyle act we've
brought a trillion dollars into our
economy which has then taxed and brought
back to us as taxpayers it's also
created something like 4 million jobs
and over 11,000 startups and it also has
a march in clause that lets say the
government gave a 2 million dollar grant
to Harvard they then patent whatever
research they found they license it to a
pharmaceutical company now the
pharmaceutical company creates a drug or
a vaccine and starts charging obscene
amounts of money for it or fails to
actually put it out because the company
goes out of business well guess what
there's a clause in this Act that allows
the federal government to step in and
take over that patent all in all this
public private sector collaboration is
what makes innovation thrive and if you
take one part of that equation out the
whole system crumbles if you let the
government run the system completely
there's not enough innovation if you let
the private sector run it completely too
much price gouging not enough
competition you need to have that
healthy balance now this doesn't mean
that pharmaceutical companies are all
good and we should not police them or
there's not shady things that happen oh
my god do shady things happen but this
vile doral Act is not the problem and
this is the crime behind letting
somebody like Bill Gates with billions
of dollars nobody elected him he has no
medical background he has no expertise
but we let people like that have a voice
in this country while we destroy the
lives of millions of people Bill Gates
is one of the greatest philanthropic
figures of our time if not the biggest
donor should we let Bill Gates guide our
medical decisions no you're right he has
no medical expertise it's not for
to guide our medical decisions but if
scientists come to Bill Gates asking for
money he's able to choose who he wants
to donate to he does not make money from
this in fact last I heard the Gates
Foundation was running 70 clinical
trials to create a corona virus vaccine
that they said that they would not make
money on they would not patent to any of
it so that the general public can have
access to it at low cost this is amazing
actually the USA Today even came out and
debunked the theory that one of the
Gates Foundation subsidiaries could have
had a patent on something related to
corona virus it just wasn't true unless
you show me evidence of the Gates
Foundation profiting from this
everything you're saying is just it's
just your thoughts and while your
thoughts are great they mean nothing
without facts if we activate mandatory
vaccines globally I imagine these people
stand to make hundreds of billions of
dollars I'm not sure who he means these
people they're gonna stand to make
hundreds of billions of dollars first of
all if the Bill Gates Foundation
actually finds the corona virus vaccine
and it's the one that's used they
already said they're not gonna patent it
they're gonna make it free so that's
already untrue there it's also important
at home for you to know that anytime the
federal government puts out a
recommendation for a vaccine it's
automatically by law covered by your
insurance company to the point that you
have zero out-of-pocket expenses are you
anti vaccine oh absolutely not I'm in
fact vaccine is immune therapy
just like interferon alphas immune
therapy so I'm not anti vaccine it's
interesting she says she's not anti
vaccine her book has a foreword in it by
Robert F Kennedy who's one of the
leading anti-vaccine dividuals and from
what I read about the background of this
documentary it was funded by a lot of
folks who are part of what's known as
the anti vaccine community why would you
want to be involved with this
documentary if you know that that's like
being horribly against the
pharmaceutical industry and then taking
money for pharma to be in a commercial
do you believe that this virus was
created in a laboratory I wouldn't use
the word created but you can't say
naturally-occurring if it was by way of
the laboratory I got
this is her giving her expert opinion
that she believes that it was done in a
lab I've seen other experts say that
they believe that it could totally have
come from nature and jumped from animal
species to human species I also don't
think that points really important
because there's never been any evidence
to say that this was deliberate in fact
if it was deliberate this would be the
worst ploy of all time it's destroying
the world economy affecting everyone and
do you have any ideas of where this
occurred oh yeah yeah I'm sure it
occurred between the North Carolina
Laboratories Fort Detrick US Army
Research Institute of infectious disease
and the Wuhan laboratory how can you be
sure there's so many biologists who have
the same specialty as you that say that
it could have easily come from a
specific animal species and then jump to
humans and then you're sure that it
happened between these laboratories I
think even scientists should be
comfortable with the unknown or the fact
that they may be wrong three point seven
million dollars flowed from the National
Institutes of Health here in the u.s. to
the Wuhan lab in China the same lab
where many people have said that this
coronavirus infection first originated
the United States gives grants all the
time in fact when you're talking about
research on viruses it takes an
international collaboration for that to
work because we know very well that
anytime you have a virus outbreak that
can spread in one country it's going to
end up in another country if the virus
has any kind of infectivity at all
that's why it becomes a pandemic so we
have to be collaborative and give
research grants and study each other's
research that's part of it that doesn't
show any kind of maliciousness or
negative intent if my husband were to
die who has COPD his lungs have fibrosis
his lungs would look exactly like
somebody with kovat 19 theoretically but
he has no evidence of infection so if
you're not testing and you don't have
evidence of infection and if you walked
in there today you know they call it
Kovan 19 if you're coming in for a
broken leg and your leg gets infected
and you end up dying from that in fact
we won't just put covet 19 on your death
certificate if you had covet 19 you were
screened and tested for and you came
positive we would that would be counted
in the death toll and you may think
that's unfair that's inaccurate it may
increase the numbers all we have to do
is look at overall mortality for the
last few years in a place like New York
City and you'll see that every
wintertime mortality spikes but if you
look at the spike for 2020 it's
outrageous how many more people have
died you may be upset about the way
we're categorizing them Kovan related
not kovat related kovat presumed but
more people are dying and the only thing
that changes kovat 19 in fact more
people are staying home now because of
social distancing meaning that less
trauma less car accidents but the deaths
skyrocketed when I'm writing up my death
report I'm being pressured to add kovin
why is that why are we being pressured
to add Kovan to maybe increase the
numbers and make it look a little bit
worse than it is no one's being
pressured the CDC puts out
recommendations of how you decide what
someone has passed from and you're free
to follow those recommendations or not
as a practicing physician I filled out
death certificates when I was a resident
I would do death pronouncements all the
time and there are things that you write
that contributed to a person's demise
for example if someone had kidney cancer
and it was in end-stage kidney cancer
and while they were dying from kidney
cancer they got a pneumonia on top of
that I would put both on the death
certificate I can't say exactly which
one is the reason they died because you
can't just say one thing so yes if
someone has a heart attack but they're
also having a kovat infection it's very
reasonable to put both on the death
certificate and counted towards the Cova
death toll now whether or not you think
this would create misinformation that's
your choice but again look at the amount
of people that have died in comparison
to the last ten years the numbers have
skyrocketed and it's simply because of
this kovat outbreak I've talked with
doctors who have admitted that they are
being incentivized to list patients that
are sick or have died with kovat 19 yeah
$13,000 for Medicare if you call it Cove
in 19 right now Medicare
determined that if you have a Cove in
nineteen admission to the hospital
you'll get paid $13,000 if that Cove in
nineteen patient knows on a ventilator
you get thirty nine thousand dollars
three times as much a thirteen thousand
and the thirty nine thousand dollar
figure are accurate this is how
hospitals are reimbursed for kovat
nineteen patients now while it sounds
like they're getting paid more to
diagnose more the reality of the fact is
these types of bundled payments actually
save us money let me explain before
these types of bundled payments the way
hospitals would bill insurance companies
for treatment would be to say we did
this we gave these medications the
patient stayed this long these are the
doctors they saw these are the skilled
technicians that took care of them and
they would bill for all these surfaces
and what we found was they were just
wasting a lot of money and not
delivering great care so what CMS did
was they said let's take an average in
an area of how much hospitals are
spending on a typical pneumonia case on
a heart-attack case and make it a
standardized payment that then the
hospital has to make do with in treating
the patient and what came out of that
well the hospital's became more
effective they said we need to be more
cost effective and we need to deliver
better quality care to get patients
better sooner so they can leave and we
can save some of that extra money for
ourselves as a profit the reason why
we're paid $13,000 is because we're
spending time resources medications on
that patient and on average it costs
$13,000 to deliver that care in some
areas maybe they'll cost less than that
and therefore you're left with more
profit in other cases it gets really
complicated and it costs a lot more than
that and you lose money but on average
it should cost around thirteen thousand
dollars that's the fair rate set by CMS
again this is very effective both in
terms of cost saving measures and
patient outcomes
now the thirty-nine thousand dollar
figure for ventilators it's not like
hospitals are getting a three times
bonus by putting someone on a ventilator
ventilators cost money respiratory
therapists needs to get billed for their
time if a patient is put on a ventilator
they need to be sedated
with expensive medications they need to
be put into the ICU
the reason hospitals are being paid 39
thousand dollars is because it costs
more to deliver that level of care it's
not because now the hospital is getting
rich by putting someone on a ventilator
the hospital's actually incentivized to
deliver just enough care in order to get
the most money out of it but at the same
time get the patient better as soon as
possible the patients I'm seeing in
front of me the lungs I'm trying to
improve have led me to believe that we
are operating under a medical paradigm
that is untrue and I fear that this
misguided treatment will lead to a
tremendous amount of harm to a great
number of people in a very short time
when used improperly ventilators can
cause lung injury this is a well known
phenomenon however when you have a new
condition like Cova 19 which we've never
seen before we try and do our best and
adapt to the situation as quickly as
possible
does that mean we're going to be perfect
and we're not going to make mistakes and
patients aren't going to suffer
absolutely not whether you're an ICU
doctor family medicine doctor
nephrologist you have protocols that
you're used to seeing patient comes in
with condition X you know treatment for
that is why you need to order blood test
a B and C to monitor their progress and
you follow these protocols that you've
learned over your lifetime and you know
how to adapt but with kovat 19 we're
seeing really unique cases that we've
just never seen described in medical
literature before so we're trying to
learn very quickly but in this process
unfortunately patients have lost their
lives this is not because we're actively
trying to harm our patients this is
simply because we're facing an
unprecedented pandemic with a viral
condition that is new to us I want to
know why Italy was hit so hard
Italy has a very old population they're
very sick with inflammatory disorders
they got at the beginning of 2019 an
untested new form of influenza vaccine
that had four different strains of
influenza including the highly
pathogenic h1n1 flu shots carry multiple
strains of the influenza virus we do
that to increase the probability of the
vaccine being successful the
cuz we have to actually predict the
strains that are gonna be circulating
that season it's very difficult and
that's why the flu shot is almost never
a hundred percent effective it usually
carries an effectiveness rate of forty
to sixty percent depending on which
viruses are out and how well we
predicted them that vaccine was grown in
a cell line a dog cell line dogs have
lots of coronaviruses and that's why
they're not testing there she said that
because this flu virus came from cells
of dogs and dogs have coronaviruses
therefore these people have corona
viruses therefore they're not being
tested honestly just it's a purely
illogical statement like there's no
other way to put that humans have corona
viruses in fact if you ever had the
common cold
the odds are once in your life it was
caused by a corona virus the two most
common virus is causing the common cold
are the Rhino virus followed by the
corona virus she's taking things that
are happening simultaneously and
connecting them without any kind of
proof of this causation experts are
allowed to have theories and a lot of
these theories will be proven to be
incorrect that's part of the scientific
process but you have to approach this
with a level of humility by knowing that
anytime you're putting out a theory it
could be wrong and I don't feel like
she's doing that here by acting as if
what she's saying is a hundred percent
accurate with no evidence to back it up
one question remains what happened to
Alba hydroxychloroquine we know that
hydrochloric when zinc this gentleman
here is a chiropractor not a medical
doctor an osteopathic physician are
working great for patients and then
found she comes out says while there's
no double-blind control to see most
study which by the way dr. Fauci is
there going to be a double-blind
controlled besito study of your vaccine
I've actually watched that entire clip
of him giving advice to patients and as
part of that advice he recommended that
if anyone has symptoms related to Cova
19 they should go out and get tonic
water he knows that there is quinine in
tonic water which is also an
anti-malaria drug similar but not
exactly the same as hydroxychloroquine
and he believes that it would help you
if you have kovat 19 however what our
chiropractor friend here fails to
understand is that the FDA limits the
amount of quinine in tonic water to
about 83 milligrams which means you're
gonna need to be drinking 12 litres of
tonic water every eight hours this is
what happens when someone doesn't have a
total grasp of scientific research
starts making recommendations the fact
that they used him in this documentary
shows to me at least that they don't
care who their sources are they don't
even check for accuracy in a survey
polling nearly 2,300 doctors in some 30
countries hydroxychloroquine was ranked
as the most effective medication to
treat the virus how is a really weird
survey it literally asked doctors what
do you think is the frontrunner for
treating kovat 19 and doctors voted
because you know they estimated which
medicine they thought was going to be
best
and they said hydroxychloroquine and it
doesn't mean that that means it works
you need randomized controlled studies
to make that happen however let me not
get ahead of myself here we are using
hydroxychloroquine in our hospitals we
are giving it to patients those who are
admitted those who are not doing well
with kovat 19 who are on ventilators
life support cannot wait for randomized
controlled studies the FDA said in this
situation we can use an EU a which is an
emergency use authorization to prescribe
hydroxychloroquine for our patients and
honestly our results thus far don't look
great because patients are still dying
taking hydroxychloroquine and the reason
why the AMA stepped in and said hey
doctors stopped prescribing this was
because the day after president Trump
announced that he thought this could be
a potential game-changer again someone
that's not a medical expert giving their
opinion the dose is prescribed of it's
skyrocketed and then there became not
enough of the medication for people who
needed it for its legitimate
fda-approved uses like malaria
rheumatoid arthritis
other autoimmune conditions the AMA was
saying you know doctors will lose their
license if they use hydroxychloroquine
the anti-malarial drug that's been on
the list of essential medicine worldwide
for 70 years
dr. Falchi calls that anecdotal data
doctor foul she does not call
hydroxychloroquine a medication that's
based on anecdotal data
hydroxychloroquine is absolutely an
fda-approved medication for several
conditions malaria rheumatoid arthritis
autoimmune conditions and the AMA has
never said that if you use it for these
approved uses you will lose your license
that is utter nonsense what they said
was if you start using it for unapproved
reasons like for the potential that it
may help with Cova 19 in patients who
don't yet need this medication
desperately you are committing
malpractice and that's a very reasonable
approach to take why because the only
people who should be taking
hydroxychloroquine before we have
randomized controlled studies to prove
its effectiveness and safety are the
people who can't wait for those studies
and who are ill now otherwise you're
just putting the general public at risk
and depleting our stockpiles of this
medication for patients who need it for
their conditions now it's not
storytelling if we have thousands of
pages of data saying it's effective
against these families of viruses these
thousands of pages she's talking about
happen in animal models and lab models
not in humans we've never compared it to
a control group properly so because of
that we cannot state that it's approved
for a use we cannot state that it's safe
to use in this condition there was an
old antiviral drug hundred-year-old drug
called sermon on the w-h-o list of
essential medicine it literally gave
kids with autism a voice a life what did
their and Monsanto do they took it away
from everybody you couldn't get it to
save your life right now and we tried if
a company a pharmaceutical company
had a medicine that worked for autism
why in the world would they give up
those profits and shelf that medicine
it's not like they're doing it in lieu
of another treatment that's gonna make
them more money we don't have a
medication for autism just like it just
doesn't make sense to me what she's
saying is it safe to say that anything
that cannot be patented has been shut
down intentionally because there's no
way to profit from it all these natural
remedies that we
you've had for ever absolutely that's
fair to say
if we had all of these natural remedies
forever
why was there disease before the
pharmaceutical industry if we had all
these natural remedies short answer is
we didn't before antibiotics we suffered
before vaccines we suffered with the
invention of antibiotics vaccines we've
drastically increased length of life in
the world to say that natural remedies
could have done all that is purely
inaccurate it just it's very inaccurate
I will say though that there is a
financial component involved in medical
research unless pharmaceutical companies
stand to make money from a product they
will not research it generally speaking
so you have to find ways to incentivize
them so I do think that in the world
there exist certain products that
because there's not a lot of money to be
made from them
they've been largely ignored that's not
the same as saying what does gentleman
just said that they've been
intentionally shut down I don't think
that's happening and I haven't seen
evidence for it especially in this
documentary the game is to prevent the
therapies till everyone is infected and
push the vaccines knowing that the flu
vaccines increase the odds by 36 percent
of getting Kovan 19 she said the ideas
to push all the therapies aside so that
everyone can get infected and then we
get a vaccine doctor foul she came on my
youtube channel and said very clearly
that it is his belief and the general
consensus of experts that if you get
sick with Kovan 19 you are most likely
going to be immune from getting it again
I would be willing to bet on my
experience and I'll bet your experience
that any virus that you have if you do
well recover and clear the virus if it
acts like any other virus you're gonna
have lasting immunity so if everyone is
in fact it with it why would we need a
vaccine it doesn't make sense we don't
want people infected with it here the
government is saying please stay home so
this virus doesn't spread and she says
no no the government wants everyone to
get sick that's why they're not letting
hydroxychloroquine be used you can't
have a
both ways and push the vaccines knowing
that the flu vaccines increased the odds
by 36 percent of getting covin 19 where
does that data come from a publication
last year where the military who had
been vaccinated with influenza were more
susceptible to corona viruses the
authors of this study actually would
disagree with dr. judy here because what
they found was by getting the influenza
vaccine participants were less likely to
get influenza they were also less likely
to get other types of viruses in general
when you look at all the viruses that
they could get what they did see with
some natural variation most of the
viruses went down someone slightly up
one of the viruses that went up where
coronaviruses this is a type of natural
variation you can't say that the
influenza vaccine caused those corona
viruses to occur and on top of it the
simplest thing here that was missed is
that those corona viruses are not the
corona virus of today they're not SARS
co2 they're not the corona viruses that
caused kovat 19 just because they're
from the same family
doesn't mean they'll behave in the same
way there's just a lot of fundamental
errors in the way that she explains this
corona viruses are in every animal so if
you've ever had a flu vaccine you were
injected with corona viruses the fact
that she said if you had a flu vaccine
you were injected with corona virus is
horribly inaccurate our immune system is
used to touching we shared bacteria
Staphylococcus streptococcal bacteria
viruses we develop an immune response
daily to this stuff when you take that
away from me
my immune system drops as I shelter in
place my immune system drops
what does doctor is talking about is
something called a hygienic theory and
this hygienic theory is actually the
exact opposite of what this doctors
saying when you overly protect yourself
you boil your children's water you don't
allow them to play in the dirt you
constantly disinfecting everything and
anything that you touch you're not
exposed enough to viruses and bacterias
so your immune system actually goes up
not drops and it actually goes up to the
point where it starts overreacting to
non threats and as a result we've seen
increases in autoimmune
in allergies because we don't have those
bacterias and viruses that we need to be
exposed to so he's right but he there's
a misunderstanding there it actually
increases your immune system or over
boosts your immune system there's a
similar theory in allergenic foods for
children before we used to not give
children peanuts and as a result so many
of them develop peanut allergies but
what we saw through medical research we
gave children peanuts early on they were
exposed to it therefore they didn't
develop the allergies which is an
overreaction of the immune system so yes
you need to be exposed to viruses
bacteria in order to be healthy and for
your immune system to function optimally
completely agree with that but now
during a pandemic when you need to
shelter in place for a period of six to
eight weeks that is not going to harm
your immune system either up or down to
the point where it's gonna destroy your
flora and now you can't protect yourself
from illness if that was the case we
would just not survive as humans as long
as we have we can easily adapt to these
circumstances especially because even if
we don't go outside we're covered in
bacteria millions in trillions of
bacteria are on and inside of us it is
part of our natural flora and just
because we not may not be going outside
a lot we still go to a grocery store we
walk our dogs we spend a little time in
the park that is more than enough of
exposure to bacteria and viruses that
your body needs in order to function
optimally and then as we all come out of
shelter-in-place with a lower immune
system and start trading viruses
bacteria what do you think is going to
happen disease is gonna spike what will
happen and I'm very confident of this
about disease going up once this
pandemic comes to an end those who were
having symptoms of some kind of medical
condition and didn't go get care because
they were worried about getting sick
with kovat 19 are then going to present
to the hospital with much more advanced
cases which is why on my youtube channel
on television I've been telling patients
if there's something you're concerned
about your body do not hesitate to call
your family medicine doctor to visit a
hospital why because there's other
options available you can do a virtual
visit you can come in through an
isolation exit where you're not going to
get exposed to kovat 19 and the reason
why we ask patients to stay away
initially
this pandemic was so we can make the
hospital safe place for everyone wearing
the mass literally activate your own
virus wearing the mask actually
activates your own virus I can't even
begin to process what that means wearing
the mask does not protect you wearing
the mask protects your respiratory
droplets from entering the environment
getting others sick and you may save
yourself well I'm not sick I don't look
sick well yeah we've seen a lot of
people who don't show symptoms actually
be spreading this virus that's why it's
been so tricky that's why it's so
different from the flu they've done such
a great job at manipulating the masses
that it's other people shutting down
other citizens and the big tech
platforms follow suit and they shut
everything down there is no dissenting
voices allowed anymore in this free
country their dissenting voices and I'm
hearing them right now and no one's
arresting them for saying this that is
the definition of free speech whether or
not a company wants to put you on their
server is not free speech it's about
public free speech you're allowed to go
say and hold any belief you want as long
as it's not putting the public in danger
I think we face a really difficult
situation and talking about takedowns on
social media for example the to urging
care doctors that were shown earlier in
this clip their video was taken down
from YouTube it's really it's a fine
line because I'm a firm believer of
putting out accurate information to
combat misinformation and I'm a firm
believer that we need to listen to
dissenting opinions until they get to
the point where they become dangerous
and/or absurd I guess when I say absurd
I think about Alex Jones salad minute I
will eat my neighbor's I think YouTube
or any other social media platform
should feel very free to take that
content down now whether or not we
should take content down of doctors we
disagree with I think it's difficult I
think in a in a situation like this
where we're in a pandemic
there's evolving medical info doctors
are allowed to have different opinions I
think that unless someone is directly
advocating for harm like eating Tide
Pods or something
I think only then should you be taking
down content and I'm blown away why
there are not more doctors like me
talking about this all over the place we
should be banding together right now
you need to wake up because your
liberties are getting taken away from
you
all because of fake news I don't know
what freedoms are being taken away from
him we're recommending people to
socially distance themselves and
enforcing that to protect the general
public and doctors are coming together
in fact I did a video interviewing 100
doctors sharing their journeys and how
different we all are but at the same
time we're so unified in our message
about getting people to stay home about
why it's gonna break our hospital system
in fact I would love to invite this
chiropractor to come into a hospital
setting and see where patients are being
treated for Koba 19 so he understands
why the social distancing is a must at
least for the short term until we figure
out what's what and then we could start
reopening America strategically smartly
and safely it's not the scientists who
are in any way dishonest they're
listening to people who for more than
forty years have controlled who gets
funded what gets published and I'm sorry
to say many many people will simply take
the money and the fame and that support
things that absolutely aren't true are
people betraying their ethics and going
for the money at times absolutely
absolutely I'm not one of those people
that believes everyone just wants to do
things for the greater good no no no
people need to be incentivized and
sometimes they make the wrong choices
and let money guide them instead of what
their initial goals were or at least
maybe their initial goals were always
money that's not a formula for success a
and B I don't think it's representative
of the medical community as a whole the
huge majority of medical professionals
nurses doctors paramedics pharmacists
they've went into this to help people
they did not go into this to make a
killing financially there's other ways
to make money where you don't have to go
through horrendous hours of education
and training for it over a decade of
your life in order to make a decent
living after getting hundreds of
thousands of dollars in loans you don't
get funded if you don't speak the party
line you don't get published that was
probably the hardest thing for me to
take is understanding
that scientific journals would would
twist the discovery that should have
healed all do I think that if you have a
radical idea in the medical community
initially you'll be ostracized yes I
think that's part of the process if you
look at any of the people that I've made
revolutionary discoveries in science
we're always looked at with a lot of
skepticism initially but you have to
approach new ideas with the level of
healthy skepticism otherwise you'll just
believe a lot of inaccurate information
and it's a very difficult job of
agencies like the NIH CDC w-h-o to
decide which theories they should test
so what we did pretty much ever since I
got out of jail we started an education
company we wake up doctors and it's very
difficult but every doctor who realized
they may have been part of the problem
has now turned that around to march
toward a better society and restore
faith in the promise of medicine I can
sit all day and talk about the things
that are wrong with medicine but as a
whole we're helping people
we're eradicating diseases we're
decreasing the strain on our healthcare
system of Cova 19 by treating patients
by finding vaccines to say that the
entire system is a fraud because she
believes it to be without any kind of
research to say that it is I think it's
a failure on her part more than it is
ours I want to leave off with a message
to my fellow doctors and medical
professionals out there I think we need
to do a better job with our scientific
communication how we talk to people we
should not resort to heavy data sarcasm
or even takedowns in order to silence
this type of information allow
dissenting opinions to be heard confront
them correct them and put the accurate
medical info out there so people can
make the decisions for themselves also
know that I'm not the only doctor
sharing this message here's actually a
video of a hundred doctors that I've
interviewed talking about their battle
with Kovac 19
[Music]